Якщо обід - то максимум двоє військовослужбовців  за столом і в шаховому порядку.
Якщо ж на шикування - то кожна рота по черзі…
І жодних ранкових зборів усім особовим складом.
За півроку "ковід" вніс корективи в усталений десятиліттями армійський розпорядок.
У нас посилені вимоги до особового складу, якщо порівняти з цивільним населенням .
Усі військовослужбовці обов'язково підлягають зменшенню перетину  один з одним.
Яким чином? Один взвод чи рота намагаються максимально не контактувати з іншими.
Засобами захис ту вони забезпечені.
Це 101-а окрема бригада охорони Генерального штабу Збройних сил України.
Вона базується в Києві. Військові щодня мусять виїжджати на охорону різних державних стратегічних об'єктів.
Тож, уникати контактів, так би мовити, із зовнішнім світом тут не вдається.
20-річний призовник з Черкас Богдан Соколов працює в медичні частині і заразився, не виходячи за межі частини.
У мене проходило в легкій формі. Нежить, кашель, температура, але нічого серйозного не було. Були хлопці з пневмонією, але у мене такого не було.
У госпіталі було багато хворих. Зі мною лежало вісім людей, а там вісім чи дев'ять палат. І я думаю, що там не одне відділення таке.
Дві з половиною тисячі українських військових хворіють на COVID-19. Щодня кількість хворих в армії зростає на майже півтори сотні.
Втім, як переконує головний санітарний лікар Командування Медичних сил, статистику протягом останніх 10 днів вдається утримувати стабільною.
Тобто критичної ситуації на сьогодні немає, щоб займатись якимись додатковими заходами
щодо госпіталізації наших військових в інші заклади, приміром, у цивільні.
Аби не перевантажувати військові госпіталі, наказом Генерального штабу кожна військова частина
на своїй території мала підготувати ізолятор для інфікованих.
Тут його спорудили у колишній казармі. Нині на ізоляції чотири військових з легкою формою коронавірусу.
Ця казарма найвіддаленіша, має окремий вхід і окремі туалети, тому найбільш пристосована до тимчасового ізолятора.
Взагалі ізолятор на 150 ліжок, але більше десяти пацієнтів у нас не було.
Якщо стан хворого погіршився - спеціальним медичним автомобілем його перевозять до госпіталю.
Військові частині мають завчасно виділити таке авто. Та не всі внутрішні розпорядження вдається виконати.
Приміром, як дотримуватися дистанції в казармах? Приміщення, розраховані на 150 чоловік, не дозволяють збільшити відстань між ліжками.
Тому поки від масового поширення нового вірусу в армії рятує рання ізоляція хворих та ретельний нагляд за контактними особами,
говорить лікарка військової частини Ірина Мартинова.
У нас є журнал контактних осіб, вони всі вписуються туди. Проводиться дезінфекція, все миється і кварцується.
Контактні, якщо мають симптоми, ізолюються. Якщо немає симптомів, то впродовж 14 днів спостерігаються. Це вимірювання температури, сатурація.
Тобто продовжується звичний режим, але під спостереженням. Якщо з'являються симптоми, тоді ізолюємо. І далі по симптоматиці.
Окрім того в армії дезінфікують і спецтехніку, яка перевозить військових по місту. Миють усе - від салону і  ручок військової машини…  до навіть коліс.
Автомобіль знаходиться поза межами частини, ми не можемо гарантувати що туди нічого не попало.
Ми не можемо бути впевнені, що там не знаходиться вірус, який потім пошириться по частині.
Відповідальний за цей процес - солдат-дезінфектор. У спеціальному захисному костюмі та протигазі він також тричі на день
розчином хлорного вапна обробляє підлогу в контрольно-пропускному пункті.
Щоправда, така дезінфекція більше нагадує традиційні армійські анекдоти про недоцільну роботу: фарбування газонів чи накази копати від паркану і до обіду…
Тим не менше ретельна дезінфекція на КПП усього, чого торкається рука людини, справді необхідна, адже потік людей тут чималий.
На території частини є і контрактники, і призовники, і цивільне населення - родичі військових.
Для усіх діють однакові правила: носіння масок, температурний контроль та обов'язкова дезінфекція рук спиртовим розчином.
Наразі на КПП випадків з підвищеною температурою майже не виявляють.
3-4 випадки на місяць виявляємо, але треба ще аналізи. Ми дивимося температуру, здаються тести, і потім на основі них ми знаємо, захворів чи ні.
Але на цей період він має ізолюватися. Щоб не було контактів.
Особлива увага в ЗСУ до тих військових, які відбувають в зону проведення бойових дій. Перед ротацією рота проходить 14-денну ізоляцію.
Якщо ж у когось проявляться симптоми хвороби, в ізоляцію відправляють усіх бійців. Станом на нині від коронавірусу померли 23 українських воїни.
А всього за час пандемії на "ковід" перехворіло 5 з половиною тисяч військових. Найбільше хворіють на Київщині.
Спалаху на Сході України за даними Командування медичних сил наразі немає.
Не допустити поширення коронавірусу в лавах армії на Донбасі - надважливе завдання для армійців.